oh hello there
I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
you know as a registered dietician a lot
of my friends and followers asking about
their bowel movements so I decide to
answer all your questions anonymously on
my new Abby's kitchen mini series Tyler
talk dear Abby I'm going on a big date
at a fancy restaurant and I may end up
at my dates house afterwards what food
should I avoid to prevent gas side gassy
Gary hey gassy Gary don't worry I'll
make sure your date isn't a total
stinker first doc you'll want to avoid
those fizzy drinks things like champagne
ear and paw and never drink out of a
straw all that carbonation takes to
build up in your stomach as gas and
straws make you gulp in air and let's be
honest it's got to go at one end or the
other now if it slips out number two
you've got three options eh
you can blame it on your date or their
driver be in the shade of fart off or
see runaway singles flailing your arms
in the air and making various vocal
noises see it's usually my go-to but
just don't expect a second date now when
choosing your meal be sure to stay away
from really heavy fatty fare things like
rich sauces cheesy casseroles and fatty
cuts of meat because they can delay
stomach emptying which causes you to
feel bloated and full also you want to
avoid those notoriously gassy vegetables
things like broccoli cauliflower kale
cabbage or at least make sure that
they're cooked which again can make it a
little easier for you to digest now when
it comes to dessert a lot of people may
want to steer clear of some of those
really high fructose fruits things like
apples pears and peaches which again can
be hard to digest so I recommend going
for things
bananas berries or Kiwis instead also if
you think you may be lactose intolerant
you may want to go with a dairy-free
dessert instead finally on your way back
to your dates place resist the urge to
freshen that Caesar salad breath with a
sugar-free mint or piece of gum
not only just chewing and sucking caused
you to swallow in air but all those
sugar-free products tend to be sweetened
with sugar alcohols and not content to
cause a lot of bloating and gas a lot of
people I say as long as you both indulge
in the garlic heavy fare no one can take
a sense well there you have it Gary I
hope that date works out for you now if
you have a burning question about poo
figuratively or literally be sure to
leave me a comment below and I'll try to
answer it in an upcoming episode of
toilet talk thanks much for watching
I'll see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to Abbey's kitchen a lot of
people ask me how i manage to get
everything done the day i like to think
it's because i'm a woman obviously but
it also has a lot to do with caffeine i
do love myself a good cup of coffee or
tea but there are definitely more
helpful ways to get in your fix than
others
case in point the Frappuccino